well efforts to rename mccarran airport
those efforts could happen as early as
tomorrow a county commissioner is
pushing to honor former senator harry
reid but not everybody's on board
christian casadas is live near mccarran
airport with what this change could mean
and most importantly who is going to pay
for it kristin
that's right denise good evening well
harry reid international airport is what
one commissioner is hoping
to make a reality now the airport's
three-letter
code which is las for the faa to
identify we're told that will
remain the same but the rebranding
itself would force
a fundraiser according to the
commissioner to cover the cost of about
two million dollars
international airport is one of the top
airports in the nation
and it's about to get a name change a
decision not everyone is on board with
yeah las vegas airport sounds fine or or
whoever they want to name it after
i for me i don't really personally i
don't see how that's going to change my
life or
my day-to-day basics or routine or
anything the airport is named after
former senator pat mccarron
who represented nevada in the 1930s but
a history of anti-semitism
xenophobia and racism have forced one
county leader
to step up and make a change it's been
talked about for a while mccarran
has been pretty controversial i don't
know if you recall but the
congressional delegation has to have his
statute removed from the capitol
a few years ago he really does not
represent nevada anymore county
commissioner segerblam recommends
renaming the airport to honor
senator harry reid he's the best-known
person from nevada in history
he's done more from nevada than anyone
in history he represents
a progress in washington d.c
that that really sends a signal the name
change would need to be approved by the
faa
i would not vote for a senator's name to
go on the airport
because i mean if you think of big
international airports like jfk
it's a big name and it's something that
is like a legacy that he left behind
he's done something good for the
state or something you know it should
well governor steve sisilak said in a
statement which reads in part
quote senator harry reid has never
forgotten who he is
or where he came from he has spent his
life and his career
lifting up nevada to what it has become
today he has helped to shape las vegas
into a world-class tourism destination
in a state that celebrates its diversity
again the county commissioners
are set to address this item and
possibly take action
tomorrow christian gossip is 8 news now